the tackle out of oregon the guy who
in 2019 was the unanimous all-american
and the winner of the outland
and morris trophies will they take the
man who joins us right here on the rich
eisen show penne sewell good to see you
sir thank you for joining us
thank you for having me on youtube it's
a pleasure it's a pleasure to have you
here on the program um i'm not just
saying this because you're
you're here joining us right now um
but uh carson palmer says he hopes that
you're the one that the
uh that the that the cincinnati bengals
take
what is your sense of what the bengals
might do with this pick
penny um i'm in no position to be like
this is what's gonna happen but to hear
carson say that it's a huge honor
and uh again shout out to him for
uh trusting to me and for me to be the
pick but
whatever it is if the bengals pick me
just know that i'm gonna give my all
my heart and soul to that organization
and to help keep
field barrel clean as much as i can so
if they pick me
if it's green and there's a gold light
but if they don't it's not the end of
the world
of course not no uh that's for sure um
but
what what conversations have you had
with the cincinnati bengals to this
point
uh just a normal cause normal
conversation them trying to pick up my
brain and my knowledge of the game or
and what my strengths and weaknesses are
and what i need to work on so this is
normal conversations going on back and
forth
who have you spoken to have you had any
conversations zoom or otherwise with
mike brown
the guy at the top of the flow chart
there uh not personally but we've had a
call where he's sitting in there
whether i'm talking to coach [ __ ] or
any one of the coaches on the coaching
staff but he's been in the room but
a little conversation here and there not
too much who else have you spoken to
drop some names if you don't mind movie
chat uh
on the bengal organization no just in
all of them
how many teams have you spoken to so far
uh
quite a many probably like 29 2019 29.
jeez you've spoken to pretty much
everybody in the national football
league uh whether it was zoom calls or
uh just regular phone calls yeah okay so
what are they asking you
what's the craziest question you were
asked give me the give me give me that
one
give me that one was it's not that bad
but
if if i had 400 dollars to my name
stuck in the area uh what do i do with
no internet access and no
uh no cell phone what
so that's probably the craziest one i've
had so you were asked you don't have
cell phone you don't have internet
access
and you have only 400 what would you do
with it
you like what would you do with a
situation like that and i was like
uh that's enough for me to go find some
internet access so like computer access
and give me a one-way flight back to
home well i'd i'd
i'd call an uber to get the hell out of
this conversation which you can't say
i think it was a conversation to catch
me off guard knocked me off my
uh i guess okay uh game a little bit but
it's not that bad
penny sewell here on the rich eisen show
what is your uber rating do you know
what that is right now
that's a win that's that's immeasurable
that's immeasurable
what do you got for me do you know what
that is uh
[Music]
what'd you say before i start that
just your four stars that's what you got
okay
so i mean i don't really tap into uber
like that but yeah okay
so because i imagine you've got to order
you can't just get a sedan either you
got to get some sort of
yeah no it's got to be a big tahoe
some sort how did you get to oregon how
did you find your way to the university
of oregon
uh man uh coach chris the ball hit me up
during the recruiting process and also
coach joe salabill there
joe salabel we have family ties he's
he's close to like another uncle to me
so
uh him and my father grew up on the
island together literally neighbors
so we had that connection and he
connected us to coach cristobal right
then and there
the moment we uh had our first
conversation we just
hit it off it was in utah at all polly
camp it was a padded camp so he was
coaching there
and we just our relationship grew from
there what was your decision-making
process about
covet 19 and and um sitting out
because of it walk me through that yeah
uh ultimately what came down to my
decision to opt out
was when the pac-12 canceled their
season the first time
and the moment that happened i didn't
know what was going to happen all the
uncertainty in the air
whether there was going to bring it back
when they're going to bring it back
and uh so with all that being said i was
wearing my options and kind of seeing
what's on the table and then right then
and there i just
decided to opt out and really work
towards the nfl is that what
has that been asked of you and those 29
zooms or conversations with the nfl
um sort of kick maybe to kick the tires
on your thought process and your desire
to play even though i don't think that's
a window into any of that but
sometimes nfl teams might not be very
well
rounded in their thoughts penae yeah uh
definitely that question was asked
obviously what might what my decision
factors was leading into opting out but
a little not all the teams but maybe one
or two try to knock me off by saying
something like that whether my passion
of the game is there
and trying to question my uh my love for
the game but
again i tell them every time it's it's a
no-brainer
for me it's a way of life uh the way i
grew up
and uh yeah if i want to go with my
background story about all that i can't
and you know here's a red flag for me if
you don't mind me pointing this out
uh penae is that and 1376 snaps at
oregon you gave up one sack what the
hell happened on that one snap
what happened uh if if i recall
correctly
i'm sure you do if this the one sack
that i gave up this it was against
uh usc and uh i tried to knock
his hands down it was a d tackle i come
inside to help shane
and uh man i thought i had him
knocked his hands down and tried to ride
him back but as i was riding back herb
was right there so he got the sack
so should we blame it on herbert is that
what you're saying no no we're not
blaming over here
what's he doing there you know guys
straight
right after that play i went up to herb
and tell them man that's on me
i'm gonna do better and uh from there on
out that was the only one
only sack i mean does that bother you
you could have had a clean sheet
otherwise literally gotten out of
college
with a clean sheet that once got to piss
you off a little bit
definitely if i had it back would fix
some things but at the end that is what
it is i learned from it and uh from
there on it was a clean flight
hey you know there is one mock draft and
we you know what you could do with mock
drafts pretty much that
that and you know uh the old uh bus
ticket can get you on a bus
so um that said i did see one where
for whatever reason due to quarterbacks
being pushed up and taken and then
everybody gets pushed down wide
receivers and things of that nature
i believe it was todd mcshea of espn who
had you falling all the way to the los
angeles chargers for you to protect
justin herbert
that i imagine obviously would be a
longer night than you certainly hope
for the first round but how special was
justin herbert first
up close and uh personal for you
and that you knew um about him before he
became
so phenomenal as a rookie in the nfl
last year yeah
man uh the moment i stepped on the
campus and to really
you can really feel his presence around
you like i didn't even know him
but the moment i was in the team theater
room for the first time he walks through
that door
it's just justin herbert's in the room
so from right then and there he always
had a big impression
uh from me and the moment we stepped on
the practice field the throws he was
making
were incredible i'm just like and the
moment i got the starting job and to
hear the ball
pass my ear sometimes it's kind of like
i was amazed at times and i would just
stop look at him and be like
what like you just did that and then uh
just carry on by my day
but yeah man to see what he did in the
league we all knew it
everybody at oregon knew it was gonna
happen day in and day out we saw
greatness and what that looked like
and uh it was just time for the world to
see yeah
his only rookie mistake was letting his
strength and conditioning coach john
lott cut his hair
um i don't know what that was about
i don't know what it was but herb still
did this thing so i think the flow is
coming back so everybody will see the
flow come back this season
and see justin herbert absolutely hair
flowing away and penesu a few more
minutes left with the top tackle
prospect on so many draft boards right
here
on the rich eisen show what's with the
uh the face paint
um that covers most of your face as you
go about your business
on the field what's where does that come
uh yeah it comes from
really it's just my mindset uh when i
put on that
face paint i feel like i'm a warrior
every time i cross that field
and i'm i'm trying to really accomplish
something every time i cross
between those lines and it's really
again a warrior's mentality
coming in day in and day out ready to
fight ready to put my body on the line
put my
my mentor on the line for the team's
success
so do you become a different person once
that comes on that's part of like your
you know obviously you're the same flesh
and blood and heart that beats inside
but
you know um uh brian dawkins used to say
once he put his uh eye black underneath
his face and uh or the uh breathe right
across his nose
um he would become what he called the
idiot man and just become a different
human being
is the face paint that kind of that for
you
yeah no it's exactly like that but i'd
say i'm a warrior okay coming in
ready to fight ready to just really put
everything on the line
and really just really uh again i said
in other
interviews i'm coming with violent
intentions and i really want to
impose my will on the game of football
okay before i let you go
um much was made by the philadelphia
eagles head coach saying that he has
um uh tested the competitive nature
of some prospects on zoom calls uh by
playing rock paper scissors with them
i don't know if the eagles were one of
the 29 you spoke to
if they were did you play rock paper
scissors with nick ciriani of
of the philadelphia people did you do
that they were one of the people but no
i did not play rock paper scissors okay
um i don't mean to give away your
strategy but if you did would you
what would you do rock paper or scissors
this is my testing of your competitive
nature i'm thinking of one right now
i swear i will choose this one you go
this is our way of playing rock paper
scissors right now over the phone on the
rich eisen show i promise you
i have chosen one you choose one right
now
i'm choosing rock i'm sorry i have paper
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i have paper and i'm just at
one of the 1300 plus that sometimes
slips past you
i got to tell you i'm sorry
uh it's all good if you want to run it
back i'm all good okay
okay very good i'm just look maybe
that's just your only loss you're going
to take in the national football league
this year and we'll just chalk it up to
that
beginner's luck rookie luck i'm more of
a veteran i knew
you saying you were a warrior that you
would throw out your fist with a lot
with a rock and
that's why i chose paper that's what i
do that's actually i give it to you i
give it to that okay so when you get
into the league
you know and you're asked to do this
from now on understand
maybe you should throw out some sort of
a a ra
you know a a scissor how about that
because other people are going to
probably
rock that's just my help for you as you
go to the draft are you going to the
draft are you
are you staying home where are you no
i'ma stay home
family walk me through your your day if
you don't mind for that one
what's the plan for your draft oh shoot
uh
so in the morning probably gonna get a
haircut
get that done okay and then uh the rest
of the day i'm just
really chilling until it's time to sit
down in front of the camera in front of
the tv
ready for the phone call so i'm chilling
the morning of
with family whatever that looks like
whether it's playing dominoes or just
okay uh eating uh breakfast or some sort
like that
and then just waiting just waiting and
then do you have your attire all picked
out you know what you're gonna wear yes
i do
what do you do can you give me a little
hint what do you got uh it's a little
tribal that's all i'm gonna say it's a
little tribal
uh polynesian suit that's it that's
all i'm gonna give to people okay uh so
one last time
uh penne just before i let you go i'm
going to say
uh rock paper scissors shoot let's try
it one more time
okay we'll see we'll see how competitive
you are and i just told you what you
should say what you should do let's see
if you're going to
if you're going to do something right
here uh on our channel
right now right now okay and okay um you
go
you go first i'm holding up for the for
the tv audience right now what it is
and then you pane sewell you say what
you say rock paper
rock paper scissors shoot okay
here we go rock paper scissors shoot you
say
paper there you go i have got him the
rock here
well done paper covers right you take
coaching
and you're very competitive that's why
you're going to be a top five pick i
think
right there you take care of yourself
penny have a good time
man appreciate it all right i'll see you
at the next level sir that's penny
sewell
university of oregon tackle takes
coaching he's competitive
sorry eagles you traded out
probably not going to get him hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here